if you were to describe his last few
days with one word it would be rescued
because all we see are people being
rescued pets - from rooftops from cars
but you're also seeing another kind of
rescue one from all those conflicts that
occurred before the flood stuff about
statues and privilege and gender
identity and trigger warnings these
stories still exist but in times of
crisis they seem to fade but some still
pop up as a reminder of how things used
to be right now there are cities
planning to replace Columbus Day with
indigenous day I don't know what to
think except that it's got to be cool to
have all that time on your hands
to debate that stuff and dry comfortable
weather meanwhile people are being
airlifted from certain death it's such a
powerful contrast at least to me now
these conflicts over statues and
historical figures they exist in good
times because we have the time to
discuss it
but a disaster rescues us from such
reoccurring division now I know we're
supposed to hate each other says the
media and it must be hard for identity
activists to see folks in trucker hats
or hoodies rescuing people of all
stripes they can't wait to get back to
the rage when the waters recede but for
now tribulation silences all tribes it's
the calm that came with the terrible
storm I can believe it I'm trying to
contrast between real reality and
made-for-tv outrage you can talk we can
have discussions about indigenous day
and all that stuff if we're not if we're
not living a horrible life if we're not
thinking about how we're going to get
back to our home yeah well this is the
problem yes and when you see the full
outrage and the stories that people try
to create and manufacture this it just
seems so disingenuous especially in the
face of what we're witnessing and the
hurricane Harvey the aftermath the human
struggling what in fact is going on on a
daily basis minute by minute we can't
even imagine it if we were put in this
position with our family and friends and
wondering if our loved ones where they
are they still haven't be done even
recovery efforts in terms of the waters
because they're too high so the contrast
is very difficult because now everything
has become this completely elevated
blown out of
portion hyperbolic catastrophe in crisis
that nobody can seem to try to get their
heads around no matter how small it is
it becomes something that is magnified
you know to 1000x
mmm you know Juan I'm really mayor de
Blasio said before the flood that he was
going to review all the hate statues in
New York City and I think it's a really
good thing that he's doing this too
because I obviously he's so shameful of
the democratic past and their love for
slavery that he's finally agreeing to
get rid of these reminders of his
party's shameful past Wow now that's a
question I forgot a quarter whereas it's
like a healthy what do you think about
Columbus Day well coughing I can't wait
to have it all oh I don't get it all oh
cool I'm in the circle Columbus sir you
know you know what strikes me is that
when we talk about the fact that the
storm comes and that's a moment when we
come together when there's crisis I
think it's true I'm reminded there was a
piece in The Wall Street Journal today
written by James Baker and Andy Young so
James Baker used to be Secretary of
State and Andrew Young former mayor of
Atlanta UN ambassador bleep and it
basically said you know we have to start
talking to each other we have to get
back to the idea of solving problems
reminded me of what the defense
secretary Mathers said he said the
biggest problem we have is not Isis or
the terrorists the biggest problem is
our political structure is so broken so
polarized we can't resolve anything here
at home we can't talk to each other
right and so to me when you see the
storm just picking up on what you said
Greg I think you're right I think that
it's a moment it's almost like you know
you see people in the military or you
see people on a police department when
you are dealing with something terrible
even with Jesse and me yelling at each
other
guess what I'd have is but I mean I
trust you would have mine it's just that
kind of moment in life where you know
what so I don't like the statue you
don't like the stitch you know what I
didn't like your mama Oh
I'm not going to say so we know your mom
is off I think your mother would grease
with one more than with you 100% of the
time he's long-suffering people in life
and you just can't picture the fact that
they have parents like Seinfeld that's
you I can't believe that you have
parents it's like you were very
carefully they had Nick yeah well now
that we feared off topic Jesse
these these student conflicts can only
happen if everything else is going great
right we're so spoiled being offended by
a statue or by a holiday is a luxury
that Texas wish they had right and you
know they're renaming holidays I just
care if I'm off or not I don't care what
you call it
indigenous feet long banana it doesn't
matter speaking of indigenous peoples
indigenous people all over the world
live in Harvey light conditions almost
every day where they lose their homes
they're worried about how wet they are
they're cold they're hungry that's the
norm for those people people act like
being offended is worse than being
starving
being wet being homeless being broke
being poor I would rather be offended by
instead of all of that stuff but people
are so coddled in this country they
can't experience discomfort they can't
experience offense they think that's the
worst thing in the world so they walk
around on eggshells protecting other
people protecting themselves and they
have all their priorities out of whack
the LA City Council is voting on a
holiday meanwhile la is like it's like
going to hell in a handbasket and
they're worried about a holiday and it's
like 100 degrees there too by the way
right now come on literally however yeah
there you go
Julian I think that all social justice
warriors should be forced to watch the
coverage of the storm non-stop just to
see what real suffering is like and how
people come together and all these lines
of demarcation kind of fade away you
know it's interesting because someone
this guy walked into my office in the
wake of Charlottesville and he said this
is the only country where we're
short-fused
so short fuse that we're going to spark
a civil war in verse
spawned two monuments that were erected
in the wake of the last civil war and I
thought that's a really good point I
hadn't thought about it that way before
well though there's this idea of like
France for transformative justice and
that is really important right people
have to feel like they're welcome and
yes it's dangerous and people have to
feel like their own unique individual
you know cultural Heritage's our
respective affected at the very least
right but it gets to a point where you
can't I lived in a country in South
Africa for two years during graduate
school where in the wake of a partay
there people are so scared of anything
that is unique nationally culturally in
any way that they have a list of like 75
national holidays and they're called
things like family day Women's Day Youth
Day you know that's where we're headed
here I don't mind at all
I do not like that they buy me a plane
ticket yeah just go down to Texas or
Lewis I think they have the most
holidays in the country really but you
don't want to get to a point where
nothing is celebrated you know what I
mean it's everything is so generic that
it actually doesn't mean anything I
think we just have to put our priorities
you know do a reset as a country in
terms of putting things in perspective
about what really matters in life the
health and safety of your loved ones
look at the people out there their lives
have been deleted literally everything
they knew things that they loved their
possessions anything that was tangible
that they created or had for their
families gone so more holidays more
statues that's the consensus yeah we
yeah all right I think we solved every
world problem